[Music]
foreign
view a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what's
making the headlines with uh the
associate editor of the daymur Kev
Maguire and The Economist for the Daily
Mail Sarah Vine welcome to both of you
so from Pages as ever let's kick off
with those the guardian has news of the
first joint strikes ever pay by nurses
and ambulance staff which will be taking
place next month a move it describes as
unprecedented the Metro mocks the
chancellor Jeremy Hunt over a video he
made trying to explain inflation using
coffee cups taking their inspiration
from Rowan Atkinson they call him Mr
Coffee Bean the businessman Sir James
Dyson writes in the telegraph insisting
that Rishi sunak's fiscal policies have
left Britain in a state of covid inertia
in the Daily Mail Tory MPS are warning
the chancellor that if he doesn't cut
taxes he'll lose them the next general
election
the financial times has details of
securma's trip to the world economic
Forum at Davos where he is said to be
pitching himself and labor as an
alternative to the current government
the express reports that King Charles
has gifted to the nation the sum of 250
million pounds from an offshore wind
farm deal which he wants to be used for
what he calls The Wider public good
the eye has seen figures suggesting that
all but a hundredth of one percent of
Court warrants to forcibly install
energy prepayment meters in people's
homes are approved without scrutiny the
star gives us a piece of its mind
reacting angrily to advice from the head
of the food standards agency that people
shouldn't bring cake to the office and
finally with a headline to suit the sun
has the latest on the Garrett lineker
Studio prank where his voice was drowned
out by decidedly adult sound effects
as you probably know anyway a reminder
by scanning the QR code you'll see on
screen during the program you can check
out those front pages for yourself while
you watch our guests so let's go
straight to them Kevin McGuire and Sarah
Vine
um nearly every newspaper with a
different headline there Sarah
um but the guardian picking up on the
news that we're going to have this
enormous strike of Health Service staff
with ambulance Crews now joining nurses
um if you thought Feb the first was big
then look out for Feb the 6th
effectively
yes no they're doubling down aren't they
and I think the the thing is that
um you know the government are trying to
sort of push through legislation to stop
um Services being suspended when these
strikes happen and I think they're not
really helping themselves by doing this
I mean doing it together just makes it
much worse for the public generally I
think it's probably not a very good idea
I think it's quite a bad move on their
part because I think it will not play
well with members of the public who have
been quite sympathetic generally to both
nurses and ambulance drivers but if they
both go on strike together then you know
the risk of people dying is actually
quite High well the guardian suggesting
between 30 000 and 40 000 nurses in
England and Wales had already been due
to Stage the fifth one day stoppage of
their campaign on the sixth but the GMB
now announcing more than 10 000
paramedics call handlers and other
ambulance staff will join on the same
date it does feel like it will begin to
grind to Halt at that point
um Kevin with it seems Steve Barkley the
health secretary suggesting that 10 is
unacceptable um that had been the sort
of halfway house that uh through a
College of Nursing and profit
yeah it was um Steve Bartley could halt
these strikes uh immediately held
secretary by starting negotiations
rather than having his uh Mega megaphone
figures uh that he showed so those
figures are nurses about half a million
nurses aren't they so there's very few
uh so certainly any minimum standards
will certainly be met in ambulance Crews
do that too but I'm surprised in many
ways that unions haven't uh coordinated
action in the in in the past you can see
the beginning to do that now
particularly on February the 1st which
is uh against the uh you know Sac key
workers Bill uh which is what the the
government's pushing through really with
its minimum uh standards when you will
have rail workers and you will have
civil servants you'll have University
lecturers and some others so these
strikes are going to get worse teachers
are voted to join in England already
been striking in Scotland um and the
government's got to enter negotiations
the only way to do it and as it stands
off and just shouts it's going to get
worse it's just gonna end the
negotiation so that Sarah herself has
said in in recent weeks it's incredible
they haven't negotiated with the nurses
in in particular I've never come across
and I have been covering employment
relations disputes at work for more than
30 years I've never come across a group
of employers the government that are so
bone-headed and stubborn on this and
inflaming the situation instead of
trying to find ways forward and looking
for common ground well we know that each
percentage that percentage Point that's
given is hugely costly you know they
also suggested is inflationary and it is
to uh to the economy we go next I mean
as I said every newspaper got to get
different headline and inflation
creeping down Sarah but the problem is
growth is too which is what is picked up
on by
um the very rich Sir James Dyson who's
writing in the telegraph suggesting that
the short-sighted and stupid economic
approach of Rishi sunax government is
keeping Britain in a state of what he
called covid inertia this is a section
of the of the press preview which feels
like trosinomics is back anyway tell us
more
well I think it feels I mean I think if
you sort of Ally that to other front
pages such as the mail today my paper
there's clearly a sort of resurgence of
trichonomics and this idea that we need
to introduce tax cuts there's pressure
on Rishi from the right of the party and
from the trust fans it's it's you know
it's a really difficult Balancing Act
for them because you know inflation has
been a huge problem but it is coming
down I mean inflation was largely due to
external pressures and the fact that
it's coming down is also largely due to
external pressures really so the fact is
that they've got to they've got to find
a way through but I do think this again
this is this awful thing with the Tory
party which is that it is that it just
can't resist the desire to eat itself I
don't understand why they you know you
know Steady As She Goes they're not
they're not doing too badly with Rishi
and this this Resurgence of the right is
just going to stir up this Hornet's list
that's what that's what James I mean
there are a lot of people like James
Dyson who are very well healthy and who
are very good at making money and we do
need that in this country of course we
need growth and of course we need
incentives
um but you know this is a balancing act
and and the whole point of this period
is to try and stabilize after what
happened with trust trust's budget which
was you know not very long ago and quite
disastrous really well well indeed um
yes uh the telegraph quoting him as
suggesting uh that growth has become a
dirty word that the burden of
regulations and increased business taxes
um means that they're effectively
penalizing the private sector as a free
win at The Ballot Box you mentioned the
mail Sarah cut taxes or lose the
election the tourists are warned and
that the mood music is almost like bring
back the National Insurance increase to
pay for social care and the Health
Service anyway Kevin where are we at
politically with this argument then yeah
Dyson who's a big brexiteer
patriotically moved to Singapore for a
while didn't he uh a lower tax regime I
think he's back now for tax reasons it's
also said in Westminster I'm sure it's
untrue that he wants a peerage so you
need to be back I'm sure that's just
scandalous
said that Kevin that's just a lie
obviously appalling isn't it that people
do
terrible terrible it's never happened
before but no but you can see on the
right of the conservative party there is
a group and they were largely trust
funds uh the Kamikaze Squad who saw the
economy crash what there was a 30
billion uh Bill put on that by the uh I
think it was the resolution found
Foundation we saw interest rates go up
and so on that are still pushing those
policies and uh you know everybody would
like to pay uh less taxes there's no
question it's gone up to a 70-year high
which I wouldn't have expected under the
conserves the the total and then as the
male side could taxes or lose the
election Tories one well if if Sunex is
going to cut taxes uh are they saying
increase borrowing but there was a time
that borrowing was a fetish of the
conservative party certainly the David
Cameron and George Osborne time which
when it was all about getting down they
didn't it went uh it went up quite
considerably certainly in in cash terms
but you can see this big row within
within the government in UK conservative
pie and we'll see you soon whatever
whatever you might think of him I think
he's got a almost an impossible job now
because I don't believe his party wants
to be left it's everybody's just going
their their own way and that will create
huge problems for him and them come the
election
uh well I mean can I just yeah sorry
no I was just going to say we've got uh
kirstama and Rachel Reeves in Davos you
know selling themselves as the next
government I mean one thing that I think
is certain that if if we do have a labor
government then then uh you know there's
no chances of taxes coming down it's
just going to go the other way so you
know I think the Tories need to be a bit
careful about this because you know they
what they don't want to do is to is to
is to create a situation where they're
unelectable again and then the person
who really will take the economy gets in
yes and what
worth just noting that a shrinking
Workforce affects growth but obviously
High inflation has tempted some early
retirees back into the workforce and the
government under Mel stride is certainly
working to work out why people so many
have left the workforce
um in the meantime who wants to reflect
on The Daily Mirror well actually Kevin
you do it's your paper
um Simon Clark uh is making the front
page of your paper um tell us more about
that yeah another brexiteer uh he was um
Chief secretary uh in the treasury when
Russia was Chancellor I think he was
briefly leveling leveling up secretary
I'm trying to remember now there's been
so many changes in the cabinet but he's
basically saying look nurses uh they
shouldn't need to use food banks that's
probably right but some aren't paid
enough and then if you have a high
mortgage rent uh you have to pay for car
parking at your hospital in England when
you go to work you have other issues and
most of them are paid less than 31 000
they're doing it hospitals have settled
food banks themselves so him saying well
budget budget better I mean it's
probably all right for him because he
must be on getting on for three times
when a nurse uh earns so I think every
time somebody speaks out and he's on the
right he's part of the Liz trust
Kamikaze Squad every time a Tory speaks
out like this I think they just make
themselves appear tenured and they
distance the UK concert of uh party from
the public uh as a whole it doesn't no
good whatsoever okay yes um seven weeks
in the job as a leveling up secretary so
your memory served you well at that
point
um in the meantime you mentioned um
secure starmer um heading to Davos
pitching himself as the alternative as
you might expect
um is is it intriguing that uh that he
and the shadow Chancellor are heading
there and yet the British pm and the UK
Chancellor are not Sarah does that
matter
um I well I think I think I think Rishi
would argue that he's got too much going
on at home to go swanning around Davos
which there was a brilliant story about
Devils this week about the number of um
uh escorts who turn up there during the
summit apparently it's very lucrative
period in their careers
um so it's not an and you know Davos is
is generally thought of you know as as
basically a lot of swanning around I
mean you know I think what's interesting
about him going to Davos and what and
the things that he said is this idea of
um
rejoining the EU which I think is
something that
um he's saying it's not what he wants
but I mean he's definitely talking about
you know getting closer again and I
think that voters will have to he's got
to he's he's got to play quite a careful
game here because obviously he doesn't
want to alienate the who read whatever
color it is now wall who voted very
strongly for brexit but he is
nevertheless saying that he wants to
strengthen ties so that's quite
interesting I think we should watch that
quite carefully
open
Kevin your thoughts
yeah um I remember John McDonald when he
was um Shadow Chancellor later Shadow
Chancellor and he was Jeremy corbyn's
Chief Lieutenant he he went to Davos I
am surprised hunt isn't going I can
understand
why sunak isn't but I'm very surprised
I've left it open to starmer and Reeves
they'll do a lot of uh glad handy a lot
of uh rubbing of shoulders uh and it'll
probably do them some good they will
begin to get taken seriously and the
problem the problem I think for the
conservatives is it looks as if they're
given up and been edged out while you've
got this ego labor team who are over
there talking to other leaders and
industrialists and movers and shakers
many many of them you wouldn't like uh
well I wouldn't like anyway but
nevertheless I can see why storm and
Reeves are doing it and the government I
think is a bit foolish to uh to give
them a free run yeah and I think yeah
and I had a very proficient performance
from secure stamina promises questions
today as well but I suppose wish you
soon X still hasn't done very many of
them learning on the job at that I guess
anyway lots more still to come story
kicked off last night of course should
we have our cake and eat it at the
office uh we'll take a bite out of that
story as does the day start
[Music]
well welcome back you are watching The
Press preview with me once again Kev
Maguire and Sarah Vine and Kevin let's
go to the eye I think the second day
they've LED on this story The Guardian
also reporting on it this idea about
prepayment meters and how damaging they
are so what's the detail in this one
I've no it's absolutely uh scandalous
that when
um companies power companies apply for
warrants to have forced entry into a
home to put in a prepayment meeting
they're just waved through uh they they
say in the eye figures show
99.99 our way through only 72 of 534
000 requests in court were were actually
stopped and huge batches
of these requests our way through this
is terrible for families because you end
up paying more and you have the the
continual worry of whether you have you
been in a shop or a supermarket or
online to make sure you have the credits
to keep the lights on keep the heating
on have hot water be able to cook uh
there is no scrutiny all the power is in
the hands of the electricity and gas
companies now remember
uh one of Sarah is friends she was
talking about talking about it recently
uh came a crawler and Sarah tried to
intervene and just got nowhere you back
you're banging your head against a brick
wall weren't you and imagine people who
don't have anyone that represent them
anyone powerful
they're so rapacious these companies
they're so rapacious and the thing is in
my in my friend's case it all happened
so quickly she didn't really understand
what was going on she had a dispute with
her supplier she'd been paying one
company they weren't and it was all very
complicated and before she knew it this
guy was at her door demanding access to
her house with a warrant and there
wasn't anything she could do about it
and she you know she got me who's
probably one of the bossiest people in
England to try and sort it out and even
I couldn't get to any of them and it was
awful the thing is is that a lot of the
people that this is happening to are not
people who are you know bossy middle
class ladies like me who can you know
who can sort of ring up and shout at
people that you know it's it's happening
to people who are already struggling
with this kind of stuff and they're
they're tired and they're worn out and
they're a bit confused and it's awful
it's really rapacious and as you said it
ends up costing more so you're so you
end up with the with the most with the
people who can afford it less paying the
most to their energy well it started to
be raised in Parliament Now isn't it and
actually I just see on the front page of
the eye
um Katie Ball's writing in the eye
trussites are plotting and the PM risks
losing control of his party and it was
the return of trust anomics which we
talked about at the uh the start of the
program in the meantime quick word on
The Daily Star I have to admit when I
saw this story yesterday
um I immediately thought about Boris
Johnson and office cakes I don't know
why but anyway there we are Let Us Eat
Cake number 10 officially urges us to
ignore a health Chief's no cakes at work
advice Sarah
hmm uh I'm I'm very much in favor of
cake at work I mean I mean what else is
there you're sitting there and although
I have to say when I first became a
journalist I did become an inordinately
fat almost immediately unaccountable the
cakes it worked so I think
um because you're doing a sedentary job
most time and unless you're sort of late
you know unless you're someone who's
doing manual labor then you probably
don't need to be consuming an extra sort
of 600 calories at tea time okay
um I've got no time thumbs up or thumbs
down from you Kevin we've run out of
time
[Laughter]
exactly anyway Kevin and Sarah thank you
both very much Julie thank you